in 2005 and 2006 when we were planning a
building many of my friends and family
and colleagues in the industry said that
it's crazy there are so many condos
being constructed in New York and the
market was going to be there would be a
glut in the market and we'd suffer just
like other places like Las Vegas and
like Palm Springs and San Diego and for
that matter Miami and what I've always
told people is you really have to always
go back to the demographics and New York
has a unique unique situation every
single family in every part of the world
wants to send their firstborn they have
brightest child to get ahead in the
world and one of the first places they
think of as New York maybe London so we
have the brightest minds we have almost
every major corporation with a some type
of headquarters here we have every
industry here and as a result the
demographic inflow of people is
consistent and it means we have a
growing population we had eight million
people just a couple of years ago we're
about eight and a half million people
now and growing so there's needs and
consistent needs for more houses and
more apartments and more hotels and more
restaurants so the demographics of New
York are positive and it's a growing
city and as a result i'm still bullish
on residential real estate that doesn't
mean price again go up five ten or
fifteen percent a year or more like they
did a couple years ago but it means that
prices will remain firm and probably
trend up over in time with inflation so
I think that New York City so New York
City with real estate is a stable
growing market in my view when we were
looking to develop residential real
estate I was trying to think of where
would be the best place to develop and
many brokers showed us extremely
inexpensive land in places like Newport
New Jersey and Newark New Jersey and
greenpoint brooklyn in Williamsburg and
Long Island City and even the world's
financial district downtown and what I
said to maddie is what we need to do is
we need to find a needle at needle in a
haystack we need to go back to my father
always taught me in real estate which is
location location location and we found
this piece of land on the far west side
in Hell's Kitchen I knew that was it why
I watched as I grew up my uncle was gay
and I saw was going on the west village
and
80's and 90's i saw what was going on
Chelsea where I came out where I went to
my first gay bar and I had lots of
friends living I had lots of friends
living and starting around the year 2000
i saw a migration of bars and
restaurants and for that matter of
friends moving to Hell's Kitchen and I
knew that would be the next Chelsea I
really did believe that and when I
bought the piece of land on West
forty-seventh Street west of tenth
Avenue everybody thought I was in the
outer outer zones of the city and I
thought it was crazy we were five minute
walk to Times Square and we're in the
heart of Hell's Kitchen and now Tenth
Avenue is becoming a little bit like
ninth avenue bartini bar opened a few
weeks ago on 45th and 10th there's a
great restaurant called 44th and 10th on
forty-fourth and tenth and here we are
in forty seventh and tenth with a robust
neighborhood the gentrification is in
full swing and to solidify that
gentrification kimpton hotels from San
Francisco just opened a hotel on forty
eighth and eleventh call ink48 and
ogilvy & mather moved their worldwide
headquarters from world fine from
worldwide plaza to forty seventh and
eleventh in July with two thousand young
professionals working there so I had a
belief in Hell's Kitchen I saw the
gentrification happening I thought it
would continue and has actually happen
much quicker than I expected
you